this is Colossus it came to life here in
England at Bletchley Park in 1943 the
machine raced to decrypt German messages
by analyzing thousands of words of coded
text every second
with its mix of vacuum tubes wires and
switches Colossus emerged as the first
electronic programmable computer its
arrival gave the Allies a huge edge in
world war two and save thousands of
lives it also marked the start of the
Information Age England built ten of the
Colossus machines and they became the
heart of its booming computing industry
actually no this is a replica of
Colossus the real machines were
destroyed after the war so that the
pesky Russians wouldn't find out about
the technology the metaphor then is a
simple one
England dismantled decades of pioneering
computing work because it seemed like
the proper thing to do and it suffered
the consequences
ever since I doubt many of you can name
a single tech product or startup that
hails from this country what you'll see
next then may come as a real shock
because in its very subdued
self-effacing way england has in fact
given rise to a handful of tech
companies that have impacted the world
on an immense scale
I'm heading from London to Cambridge and
into the English countryside to find the
best technology that England has to
offer along the way there will be
adorable children building computers
fancy hair dryers an AI infused software
so little my name is sofa
what is your name and of course there
will be a spot of tea all on this
episode of hello world
Silicon Valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them if you tried to design the
perfect University town you would
probably fail to think of something as
idyllic as Cambridge
it's a city filled with temples to
learning and young privileged brainiacs
hop on a bike and you can go on a ride
through academic history from Newton's
apple tree right on up to the pub where
Watson and Crick drink to celebrate the
discovery of DNA's double helix if that
seems boring you can also be ritually
abused at the old Cambridge market
Thanks oh it's like sour soap today
Cambridge also serves as the heart of
england's tech industry with its
research centres startups and massive
biotech firms outside of the university
the biggest reason for Cambridge's
technology success is a company called
arm it designs chips and they're the
brains at the center of almost every
iPhone and Android smartphone in short
the modern world runs unarmed I've met
up with my old friends an arm co-founder
Mike mother to share a warm British beer
and find out how this happened we're in
a pub what is a meant arm over its
history
we met our first CEO in a pub we are in
the pub that's about a hundred yards
away from where we actually started and
in those days we used to come here every
lunchtime so yeah it's played an
important part in the business right arm
started on something of a whim its first
major customer was Apple which needed a
chip for its upcoming Newton handheld
device instead of making a screaming
fast super hot chip like everyone else
arm decided to make a low-power
energy-efficient chip soon enough
making low power chips became arms thing
it took a while for the bet to pay off
but once mobile phones and then
smartphones arrived arm ended up as a
major force lifetime our partners are
shipped over
80 billion different chips and last year
there was about two per person on the
planets as about 15 billion ARM chip
ships so there in everything phones
printers anti-lock brakes televisions
Wi-Fi Reuters cloud servers medical
devices I could keep going traditionally
you know the big powerhouses of the chip
industry made their chips they branded
themselves they very boastful about it
all you guys have been happy to stay in
the background yeah and maybe that's
because we're at I'm slightly British
slightly understated and have been quite
happy to work in partnership with people
and let them stand up and shout out
about their products sometimes you walk
down the street and think well nobody
actually knows who we are or what we've
done and that's what the business model
about partnership is you let other
people innovate around what you do and
take take the glory Tomales point one of
the most innovative and glorious things
built around an ARM chip is raspberry
pie it might not look like much but this
$35 assembly of electronics is a fully
functioning computer there's the ARM
chip right here tons of USB ports and
Ethernet port even an HDMI port with
this teeny little thing you can do just
about anything
released in 2012 the PI has inspired
near religious devotion among geeky
hobbyists and inventors some of them
show off their PI creations at things
called raspberry jams
I went to see David pride who has a
shrine to the low-cost personal computer
at his home in Gloucester what is this
little device meant to you it's changed
my life I was very happy very stable dad
a nice well-paid job that I was very
very bored and I realized that boy ever
wanted to do something different this
was this was the opportunity to learn
the skills that I'd always wanted to
learn electronics robotics coding his
house is littered with pie creations
from motorised cars to robots greetings
to everyone watching hello world that's
a nice touch his most famous invention
though is the four bytes an AI infused
machine that plays a mean albeit slow
game of Connect four that is cool how
long did it take you to make this about
three months of evenings and weekends
connect four is actually quite a complex
game there's an awful lot of mathematics
behind the AI that runs the system so it
makes it you you know oh I have to go
you make your move but it is now
thinking about the movies taken
oh you bastard you've just lost I feel
ashamed I feel like I should've done
more for the humans
to really understand the soul of the
Raspberry Pi
I had to head back to its birthplace in
Cambridge and dig deep into the city's
traditions this met humiliating myself
through something called punting which
is like canoeing except dumber and more
frustrating whoa all right
whoa June so you pull it all the way out
yeah yeah
how do people deal is that he's pretty
intuitive my punting coach is a Ben
Upton easy
he's the Cambridge computer scientist
who invented the pie around 2007 Evan
grew alarmed by the declining number of
computer science students in England and
decided to try and inspire the
youngsters with a new approach I've
always assumed Cambridge is the best
place in the world to study could be a
science and certainly the best place in
the UK and we saw this collapse and a
number of people applying to study
computer science at the University of
Cambridge which is crazy as their
computing industries blow yeah yeah your
computer's playing obviously it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful environment
to come and to come and study in the
theory we came up with was that most of
us who were arriving in the mid-90s like
I did I had grown up with cheap
programmable 8-bit microcomputers you
grew up using the BBC micro my grads
what got you again I said I had a BBC
micro school to start in the corner of
the classroom and those are beautiful
machines supported by the UK government
the BBC micro gave many students their
first taste of coding and the
possibility of what computers could do I
screw holding the pie has very much
followed in this tradition and emerged
as a consumer hit along the way it's now
the third best-selling computer of all
time behind the Mac in the PC our
lifetime dream volume was 10,000 units
now we're closing them on 10 million but
as that's happened we just got war
ambitious we just got more greedy I
guess about what we're trying to
accomplish we've gone from can we move
the needle from 200 to 600 people
applying to computer science at
Cambridge - yeah can we do the same for
other universities can we do the same
for other countries could we do the same
for other subjects think big Jason
Statham impersonator think big
coming up next hi Daisy
oh I interview a baby about the future
of artificial intelligence the
intellectual underpinnings of computing
began here in Cambridge in 1833 the
Cambridge Train mathematician Charles
Babbage built a prototype of this thing
the difference engine it could solve
equations with the turn of a crank and
some gears and is considered the first
mechanical computer a hundred years
later in the 1930s another Cambridge
mathematician named Alan Turing devised
the concepts behind the modern-day
computer
he proved that a machine can be
programmed to calculate just about
anything
decades after Turing and Babbage
Cambridge is still at the cutting edge
of computing companies like Microsoft
placed their research centers here to
tap into the local academic talent and
to explore their most ambitious ideas
Chris Bishop runs this lab and oversees
research in a number of areas one of the
most compelling and frightening areas is
artificial intelligence this is not just
an amazingly exciting time in artificial
intelligence more and more tasks are
becoming solved in image understanding
in speech recognition and so on so
though we've got a very long way to go
before we get to the the full
capabilities of the human brain there is
a sense that for some kinds of tasks
sort of the barriers have been removed
computer scientists have dreamed of
creating a true artificial intelligence
for decades they've been hunting for a
machine that can equal or surpass humans
recently people like Bishop have started
to make real headway thanks to an
approach called machine learning if you
go back to the time of cheering
computing is about logic is about
determinism and the the code the
instructions which the computer runs are
created by a human what we're seeing in
the machine learning is something very
different instead of programming the
computer to solve the task you program
the computer to learn for an experience
and then we train the computer by
showing it also examples giving it lots
of data AI powers a ton of experiments
here including this computer vision
simulation Microsoft's Kinect sensor
used to struggle to make out a hand and
now it can pinpoint the movement of
fingers there's also an AI powered movie
recommendation algorithm for Xbox that
does a pretty good job at figuring out
my eclectic taste in movies you know
actually I mean I did like twister okay
let's see what happens this time so now
we see a big change this lab isn't just
about entertainment though they're
actually saving lives with the program
that can tell the difference between
cancerous brain tissue and healthy
tissue in an MRI what you see here is a
pretty nasty brain tumor that oh it's
not a good show it's not great it's not
great so what the machine learning is
doing now is it's labeling it according
to whether it's tissue that's already
died or whether it's tissue that is
cancerous and proliferating this is
really important because this is used to
design treatment so we'll fire in
radiation from lots of different
directions and we'll tune up the amount
and direction of the radiation to try
and kill as much of the cancer as
possible but to do as little damage to
the normal tissue as we can
down the street from Microsoft there's a
start-up that already has its AI
technology in the wild
it's called audio analytic and you can
think of it as a type of Shazam for
real-world sounds we use artificial
intelligence to allow smart home devices
to recognize a whole range of different
signs that happen inside your houses it
can make your house a bit secure by
detecting glass windows being broken and
then turning a light to scale where in
the burger I should take an active
protection of you know things you care
about so what do we have here what what
is those um so we've got a couple of
devices that make the sounds that this
detects smoke along see it's detected
smoke alarm on there nobody's at home so
it's now sending a iMessage another
sound this is glass break yeah that that
off you can see it says window broken
yeah
what is the science by louis we have to
do a whole bunch of innovation in terms
of understanding sounds how to detect
them and to have a machine understand
them even if we take a simple sound like
a smoke alarm good beep well now we've
got two of them go beep at different
times with a whole bunch of background
noise going on that's a big AI problem
to solve computers have to be trained to
distinguish one sound from another and
to learn the unique signature of say
glass breaking audio analytic trains it
software by presenting it with examples
of a particular noise of course no two
breaking windows sound exactly alike so
these guys get to relieve stress
by breaking a lot of glass how many
windows have you had to break windows we
literally build warehouses for it on
months on end different sizes different
thicknesses different type of glass
how many smoke alarms smoke alarms we
literally bought all smoke alarms you
can find on the market place and then
index to all those that was a huge
undertaking logistically the software
can also recognize the sound of a baby
crying hi Daisy
oh hi and as luck would have it we found
a cute hungry baby on which to
experiment so you can see on the screen
is detecting the baby cry
audio analytics software already ships
inside a number of smart home products
and the company plans on adding many
more sounds
but for now it's the perfect technology
to discover when an angry baby has
thrown a smoke alarm through a window
I'm sorry we have to do that she was
very sweet well done the first TV show
next up I head to London to explore more
serious matters like getting the perfect
hair day I feel like I'm two inches
taller down I arrived in England at the
height of brexit mania the tourists were
happy because the entire country had
gone on sale some of the locals were
morose and some of them just didn't care
like the people drinking these $20
cocktails at a fancy hotel bar
nothing says hello to financial ruin
like sipping rum from an elephant made
of Legos or gin from whatever this is
you know who else doesn't care about
brexit people willing to pay $400 for a
hair dryer
Dyson as we all know has perfected suck
now it's on to blow meet the supersonic
according to the ample Dyson propaganda
this is the smartest hair dryer ever
built it uses an electric digital motor
to produce an intense stream of air and
then sensors to make sure that air never
gets too hot as a result your hair comes
out shinier and healthier than ever
before I feel like I'm two inches taller
down
to see how Dyson built this thing I had
to leave London and head to the
company's headquarters in the
picturesque town of Malmesbury James
Dyson founded this company in 1991 and
has created his very own engineering
paradise the Dyson campus is littered
with his toys of course you have a plane
in the cafeteria
and made up of a handful of invention
factories my first stop is with someone
who leads a constant battle to come up
with ideas for brand new products and
reinvent some old ones hair drawers just
haven't changed in sort of 60 years if
we look at this this cutaway here you
see they've got a very large motor
inside like that but that weight you're
holding you know for 20 minutes half now
where you're drying your hair and very
very noisy so we thought it's a really
good product for us to get into Dyson
spent four years in 71 million dollars
to bring the supersonic to life and as
you might expect they're
obsessive-compulsive when it comes to
him we felt that we had to learn
everything about how the science of hair
we had to put our own laboratory to
learn about how for ourselves
and know what causes damage what causes
shine what makes your hair look lovely
hi Matthew hi welcome to lap 61 oh did
you very much ask you to put a lap go on
because this way there's gonna be kept
spotless
Matthew child is Dyson's electric motor
wizard he spent more than a decade
developing the core of so many Dyson
products the vacuums have big motors and
the hairdryer has this tiny thing
a miniature turbine this is more tuned
to a jet engine you find on a commercial
airliner than anything else how fast
does it spin around one hundred and
fifteen thousand rpm so that's about
eighteen hundred revolutions every
second yeah it seems almost impossible
it's possible through very fast
electronics and a mechanical system that
is able to take the stresses the strains
for hundreds of hours at full speed the
electric motor technology will be key to
Dyson's continued push into new product
areas some people say it's secretly
working on an electric car what types of
things would this be useful in people at
the moment we've applied it to the
hairdryer to weigh and see what comes
next
I knew you would say that can only say
that and with that it was time to head
back to London for one last visit with
the pie people and a startup called Ken
Oh
founded in 2013 kena took the idea of
bringing Raspberry Pi to kids very much
to heart it's built a series of
do-it-yourself computers based on the PI
to teach children how to make
electronics from scratch and how to code
these three lovely children agreed to be
our DIY guinea pigs and to take a crack
at making a can oh well should we let
you guys get to it you want to start
building yeah take it away
is it fun to build your computer instead
of just grabbing an iPad yeah what's fun
about it Oh
if teaches you about BEC why do you like
tech cuz I want to be an inventor when I
grow up it's a typist the dude floating
around the office is Alex Klein a
co-founder of the company he's a former
journalist who decided to give up on the
most noble profession imaginable to help
kids get their hands dirty with
computing November of 2012 we were
playing around with the Raspberry Pi you
could do so many things with it at the
time developers were sending it into
space they were sending it under the
ocean but we were having trouble getting
started so you want to make a kit that
was simple enough for a kid to build
themselves yeah exactly this generation
they have only experienced computers in
the post jobs era you know perfectly
polished constrained consumption devices
the notion of counter was to break it
apart and let a young person build a
computer from the inside out what do you
think cycle yeah
for Alex it's all about creating tools
that inspire and encourage creativity
you know they're building apps that are
worth millions you know they're solving
local problems in ways that their elders
could never comprehend if you give them
something that's as powerful as you know
a main lung developer something that can
make a robot something that can make a
server you'll see what this generation
can do they really have the power to
make something that does your cooking
cleans up your rooms and fixes your
stuff inside of the children doing
chores that would be amazing with that
as these children will soon learn it's
basically considered rude to be
successful here
England's beloved cynicism runs counter
to the hype filled optimism that
dominates the tech industry the Brits do
a fine job at promoting a pub lunch but
do less well at spurring on
entrepreneurs and inventors it's clear
enough though that when the English
really gets stuck into something they do
it well it's not hyperbole to say that
armes chips have changed the world or
the raspberry pie may well have altered
a generation for the better and if
you're inclined to try and think big
there remains no better place to do it
than in Cambridge where you can meditate
in peace among the cows
up next on hello world I head to Japan
and wake from a fever dream to find this
this and whatever this is